[Music]
have you guys ever stopped
to think about how do how do all the
cairns in the world
feel right now like the actual name the
real character real cairns
yeah i like the name karen but then i
don't like karen's
yeah the racist karen's that's yeah i
think the real karen's are
pissed because they can't even see why
people are mad at them
you know what i mean because they're so
stuck in their tunnel vision wait we
talk about when you say real real life
people like my name's karen like how
what i feel if my name is
they feel bad probably i'm like damn i
didn't do many things
[ __ ] how come it's settled on karen
because people used to be like susan
they used to say
rachel and why is it only women why
aren't there any guy once oh kevin
kevin's kevin's or ken's right yeah i
feel better ken's or kevin's
kevin i've seen kevin's i like ken
better candace is
barbie yeah well because ken feels more
white you know kevin has
so many kevin trans and kevin owens in
the world that's because you're
vietnamese yeah
so many that's like the most common
japanese name
that is it is the only ken i know is
from street fighter
which is a white japanese blonde hair
yeah yeah yeah he's a japanese guy with
bleach
blonde hair and blue eyes and lives in
america no he's
he's actually a white guy that was born
in japan that's his backstory
he's a military baby can short for
anything can
no it could be ken ichi it could be ken
yeah because i knew someone named
kenneth
we never called him ken oh like the
american ken word
or whatever oh kenneth paltrow kenneth
paltrow
yeah but kenny like kenny g must be
short for something kenny
kenneth kendrick sounds right kenneth
right kenny g is japanese
anyway
so i think karen's are pissed as well i
like virgil the real
karen's the real life named karens not
the racist character the non-bitches
that
are just unfortunately named karen for
now it's so funny because
these chara like this caring behavior
has always existed right and we would
laugh at that [ __ ] but there was never a
name
to that can i see the manager lady yes
yeah it's just that short-haired look
with that hair and that yeah
everyone knows what it is but it took
this long to like
identify what that is but it sucks
though that it's being labeled as
karen and i bet you the person who
started that was susan
oh yeah or nancy
right oh yeah nancy nancy makes a lot of
sense yeah
[ __ ] karen you know they're the karen
it was her sister growing up do you see
people protesting against
like usage of the word karen as if it's
like a sl
like they're like it's it's equivalent
to an n n-word yeah i'm like
what you [ __ ] karen ass [ __ ]
do you think the people protesting are
named karen i don't know because then
i'd be like you get like one point of
merit
then it's like it's hard to say like the
karen's all march let me tell you about
the real life karen
okay what about it what about it named
karen so there's a new union that they
created because of this
so they're in the uk they had started a
petition a change doctor oh god
it's titled to stop the use of karen to
describe racist
women in the tabloids and then the
description says my name is karen and
i've had enough of my
oh shut up foreign friends being used to
describe
racist women in the tabloids this also
applies to other names like susan
to be described as a collection of
terrible people in the media it's unfair
to use a name to describe
a collection of women who are racist and
not law abiding
as a karen this is upsetting and unfair
please help me to get this stopped
and then everyone is like you know this
is the most caring thing you could have
done right
does she offer alternatives karen's
usually don't
no she did she's like can't we just use
rachel
i guess he's racist because that is his
solution
it's like can we just name people with
what they're doing like
if they're being a racist just name them
racist but it's not funny
it's not funny yeah you don't have a
sense of humor lady it's just sarcasm
no well she did mention too she was like
i mean the irony is not
beside me like i have seen the memes i
have laughed at at the
karen and in the beginning she said it
was all lighthearted and like oh yeah
that's hilarious haha karen
but she's saying that now that like ever
since the blm protest started they have
been using karen more
and for this particular karen she was
just saying like
now we're so she said we're labeled as
racist entitled anti-masters and we're
just not that sort of person it's
totally unfair and we want the media and
the tabloids and the papers
so that is a caring thing to do because
she thinks that the whole world revolves
around about
and it's not even about her yeah that's
exactly such a caring thing it's like if
joe took it on like he's like can you
stop calling average people joe's
yeah cuz i'm not average yeah i'm very
unique and my name is joe and
um i'm not represented correct the
average joseph i don't care about [ __ ]
or the johnson we stop referring to
toilets as
john can you stop referring to buy
to guys that buy hookers no if you're a
yeah
if you if you buy prostitutes you're a
john true what about peters
out there that are like peeping oh no
toms that's what it is peeping toms
peter peters are like little dicks right
yeah peters i don't know peter
yeah this [ __ ] is tripping stop being a
karen karen oh
that's pretty much what a lot of people
i remember though karen's
weren't used to describe racists it was
more like
entitled middle-aged ladies that
have no idea that they're being so
selfish right it's different between
that and racist because racist is uh
especially in today's
understanding too it's a i don't know
it's a much more harsh
and a much more i feel like especially
with racists today you're like fighting
a way larger war
in terms of the conversation but with
karen you're specifically talking about
characteristics of a person
and their kind of isms that make them
who they are that maybe
are kind of like half steps into the
concept of racism
but because there's the overlapping like
venn diagram because they're also the
same like the same person i want to talk
to your manager
is the person that's like at the liquor
store like hey you better speak english
here
yeah so although it's not like it's it's
starting to get more into the races it's
the hallmark
of [ __ ] calling the police is
calling like the manager of the city
pretty much the races they're like yeah
there's a bunch of mexicans at the park
let me call the police let me get the
city's manager over here
and this lady that wants to have this
petition she's making it sound like
people are going and trying to find all
the karen's in the phone book and going
we gotta get
these [ __ ] it's like no you stupid
[ __ ] it's just the characteristics
that people hate not the name
karen but they're like isn't that the
same thing as racism though you just
kind of label it one thing and then you
call them all
out on that and it's like it's not the
same you [ __ ] [ __ ] i think this is
the first time
they're facing how it feels like to be
categorized
oh so they're like oh my god this is
wrong
and it's like that's deep do you think
there are middle-aged white women who
like really like the short haircut
but then now it's known as being the
karen haircut and they're like i can't
wear this anymore
dude you know i read i forgot the exact
statistics but ever since this whole
caring as a racist thing there haven't
been
a single baby girl named karen no i'm
surprised that there aren't people
naming their babies karen's out of
protest
you know be like [ __ ] these guys this is
a karen that would
kind of be a terrible idea yeah like how
does that work
because think about people who like are
like anti-mask right i'll purposely be
like
yeah no mask i'm gonna put my face in
everything i'll lick the door you know
and there are ladies who lick the doors
out of protest right
just like naming your child out of spite
yeah internet spy
people lick door handles out of spite so
naming the kid
do people eat hornets that's what like
that's like that
medieval thinking you know where you're
like we're a family of [ __ ] racists
your name's karen passing it on we're
not gonna
get watered down i think like whatever
is the forbidden thing
people who are desperate for attention
they go for it
they're like oh well we can't do that
i'm gonna stand for something
yeah and i'm gonna [ __ ] raise a karen
to not be a karen
how about that that's awesome you know
or to be extra caring
yeah like remember always call the
police
always oh so they are raising them to be
a karen live up to your name [ __ ]
it's kind of like the name always ask
for the manager i was always thinking
like
imagine if you're german and your last
name was hitler
like do you think all of the people
there changed their last name and said
we don't want that name anymore yeah i
think a lot of people did
but what if it was a common name like
johnson
maybe you don't have to because it's
common yeah but then what if everyone
was like oh that's a bad name let's
change it all
would you change it i think you'd keep
it huh
and tattoo it on your back i would
change it if it's hitler
if i'm american maybe maybe keep it no
no not
keep it if i'm american because i don't
if it's common in
in germany hitler is just so it's i mean
that's such a
unique name right so you walk around
somewhere like you're you're doing
attendance your kids do an attendance
school they're like just
uh hitler peter
[ __ ] no like and you gotta raise your
hand when your name is called and maybe
it's like
how you raise your hand you're like i
know right oh yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you stop that oh [ __ ] i don't
you're just like and
everyone's looking at you
damn karen's karen's making a change.org
like that
uh is almost similar to you know maybe
somebody
putting up a change.org saying like hey
don't be racist to this like large group
of people
just because i think that's how they
view it right but then i think the
majority of people are like
but no one's nobody's being racist or
anything towards karen's
no one looks at a kid no one looks at a
carrot and goes oh
you must be a karen yeah [ __ ] karen
you're gonna call the cops on me
well to like give them some some like
benefit of the doubt we don't know what
they experienced because
they might be going through that like
like well they're going through that
because they're acting like a [ __ ]
karen what what's the checklist
what's the checklist of like to be a
karen like you remember a couple years
ago when uh hipsters was a huge thing
hipsters and then one of the biggest
things about hipsters was
hipsters don't think that they're
hipsters right so then there's like huge
checklists that came out it's like you
drink starbucks every day you do this
you don't admit to being a hipster blah
blah and there's this checklist what is
the manager saying
yeah what's what's the karen checklist
right so karen
the pejorative cause there's gonna be
people watching they're like wait [ __ ]
am i a karen so it says karen is a
pejorative term
used in the united states and other
english-speaking countries for a woman
perceived as entitled or demanding
beyond the scope of what is appropriate
or necessary a common stereotype is that
of a woman
white woman who uses her privilege to
demand her own way at the expense of
others yup that sounds about
right what are more fun objective things
that have like examples of karenism
if you have the impulse to correct other
people's behavior
after a accident happens so like at a
shopping at a supermarket like
someone just parked their shopping cart
over here and you have to go you can't
park over here
you know what's funny um it's on the
wikipedia page of it
it says like pictures of kate gosselin
are often used to depict karen who's
kate goss
kate the caden john and kate oh
like that haircut is like yeah that is
my hair have you seen
that one meme it's like a table full of
cairns
yeah yeah and then and then it's a key
and peel
a picture of him sweating because a
bunch of karen's asking for the manager
he's gonna ask for the manager
[Music]
you